hello my name is stockland
i'm senior director of scientific
affairs and marketing
at bio nanogenes and i'm excited to talk
to you today about our genome imaging
technology
and how it allows you to detect
structural variants
genome-wide in an unbiased way all the
way down to one percent
allele fraction and when we're talking
about structural variation we're talking
about these large rearrangements of the
genome
where there's typically no major gain or
loss of material
it could be a balanced event like a
inversion or a translocation or an
unbalanced event
like a deletion insertion or repeat
expansion
and when you attend conferences like
this
you may know about spatial sequencing
and long read sequencing but the truth
is that
in the clinic say when a leukemia sample
is analyzed
structural variation is detected with
this method
cytogenetics specifically a karyotype
which is really almost a century-old
technology
where you just crack the cells open like
an egg and look at metaphase chromosomes
with a microscope that is the standard
of care
and when ngs was introduced there was
this idea
that sequencing could replace all of
these older methods
and that hasn't really turned out and
the real reason is that these
uh ngs instruments didn't come with a
microscope but they came with a blender
and this may seem like a silly analogy i
think about this
how would i be able to tell you how many
pieces of kiwi were in this blender and
where they were
after i turn it down to make a smoothie
it's impossible right but that's exactly
what you do with ngs
you take a structurally perfect genome
and blend it shred it
in tiny little fragments of a couple
hundred base pairs analyze those piece
them back together and then you try to
figure out what the structure looked
like in the first split
it just doesn't work and the other
problem with mgs is that the human
genome is
highly repetitive with just about a
third of the genome consisting of unique
sequences and two thirds consisting of
repeats
so now if your read length is only a
couple hundred base pairs long
and you get a read back of this two
thirds of the genome it's impossible to
say
where that read exactly mapped to and
you can say well
i don't care about repeats but the
problem is that
structural variants are often flanked by
repeats and they typically are caused by
the recombining in non-allelic
homologous recombination
of these repeats so if you're using a
sequencing technology that is blind to
repeat
you're also blind to the two-thirds of
the genome and the structural variants
that are flanked by them and that is why
this is still the standard of care to
look at large structural variation
and the reason why this is such a robust
robust technology is because they
visualize patterns on intact dna
molecules and they look at
changes in these patterns to identify
rearrangements of the genome
and that's really what bio nano does as
well
but instead of a karyotype we use nano
channel arrays to massively parallel
linearize
extremely long dna molecules and
megabases in length
and and then we place more patterns on
these molecules so in a karyotype you
have a couple hundred bands
we add 500 000 of these bands to the
molecules
but then also here we look at these
patterns on these long dna molecules
to call structural variants and our
microscope
is called sapphire and it automates the
imaging
of these long molecules
so aneta provides entire workflow we
have the sapphire instrument
we have the chips that linearize the dna
we have consumables for dna isolation
and labeling and i'll talk about that in
a minute
and then we have our own software called
binano access to analyze
that data
so let me tell you real quick how it all
works
first step in isolating mega base paired
dna
is to get these molecules uh without
shearing them
out of cells and we have our own
extraction kits that we call by nano sp
they're very gentle and they work with a
disk that the dna binds to
paramagnetic disk and these
dna isolation protocols are fast they're
faster than the typical kyogen kit
they require just 650 microliters
of fresh or frozen blood we can work
with bone marrow aspirates as well
we can work with culture cells a million
and a half or we can work with as little
as 10 milligram
of fresh or frozen tissue that could be
a
cancer biopsy now keep in mind
that we cannot work with ffbe treated
cancer samples because
the dna is just too fragmented there
now the molecules that we collect with
this method are extremely long
if you look at this distribution here
you see that the molecule and 50 which
is somewhat of the weighted average
of the molecule length is over 400 kb
with a tail that goes all the way to two
and a half megabase pairs
in comparison there on the left what the
typical
read length is with long reach
sequencing you see that that's orders of
magnitude
less than these very long molecules that
we isolate
and it matters of course because these
long molecules allow you to spend
these repetitive areas of a genome
now once we isolated that megabase size
dna
we label a specific sequence motif all
throughout the genome
we do that in a single enzymatic
reaction that simply attaches a
fluorophore directly to the dna
in a single step it's a very robust
reaction and we label a single
six base pair sequence motif all
throughout the genome
so there's no probes there's no variety
of labels
it is simply a single six base pair
sequence motif
and that creates a barcode on these very
long molecules that we can
identify the labeled dna is then
linearized into
our nano channels and that is really the
core technology that our company was
founded on
our ability to make these very long
molecules squeeze into narrow channels
and once the molecule is in that channel
it is uniformly stretched
and we can get all the information that
we need just by taking a picture
that's exactly what happens here you can
see that these blue lines
in the bottom half of the figure are all
individual molecules of double-stranded
dna
that each sit in one of the channels
shown above
we stay in the background in blue with
an intercalating die
and then the green dots that you see are
these
labels attached to that six base pair
sequence motif
now the instrument will cycle molecules
into the nano channels
image them pull new molecules in image
them and do that over and over and over
again
and with that we can collect 100x
coverage of nine human genomes
per day or you can simply
run these chips longer and collect as
much as 400 x
and three samples per day or now we're
even allowing you to collect as much as
1600 x coverage
that run can take anywhere between two
and four days
for three samples so you can collect
a massive amount of data and i'll tell
you in a minute
why you would want to do that
now once these images are collected the
instrument
will analyze
these images and identify the molecules
in each of the pictures and the digital
representation of these molecules is
then
aligned with each other pairwise in a
complete anova assembly of the genome
that is an incredible uh powerful
and compute intensive procedure where we
pairwise align every molecule that we
image with every molecule that we image
and we built these consensus genome maps
that you see at the bottom there
in blue that represent the average
spacing of the labels
on each of the molecules that we imaged
now
these de novo assembled maps shown in
blue here
are then aligned to the reference genome
of your choice if you work with a human
genome that's hg19 or 38 but you can use
with any
reference of your choice for other
organisms as well
and so if the reference here is in green
then you can see that
the left half of that map aligns
perfectly the right half aligns as well
but in the middle there there's a
deletion
there's a number of labels that are
missing and the other labels are pushed
closer together
and our software will call that and as a
matter of fact we call every single
major type of structural variants using
this same mechanism so you see on the
top
left that we call deletions when the
spacing between labels is moved closer
together
an insertion is similar when the spacing
between labels increases and we call
those automatically starting at 500 base
pairs
we can look at the repeat arrays either
like shown in the image here where we
have
a label per repeat but if not we can
measure the flanking labels
and measure that spacing and i'll show
you an example of that
we can detect tandem duplications where
a pattern is present
in two copies next to each other direct
or inverted
starting at 30kb we can detect
translocations when the novel map in
blue here aligns for half of one
chromosome in half with another
chromosome
and then we can detect inversions as
well which are really hard to pick up
with most methods
because there's no gain or loss of
material but when a pattern is simply
flipped around
we can detect that automatically
starting at 30kb as well
and then when you look at your genome
analyzed
by nano you see something like this this
is called a circus plot
the lines in the middle in magenta that
you see are translocations between the
different chromosomes
and then in concentric circles from the
middle we have a copy number tool that
works just like array or ngs copy number
by counting the molecules aligning to
each part of the genome
and then we see inversions deletions
insertions as well now when you click on
any of these items you're taking to a
map
like this where you zoom on zoom in on
the exact break point
you can see the copy number change on
top and the translocation right there in
the middle
and then we can even show you the
molecules that we image that align
to that structural variant and show
evidence for it now if you don't want to
work with our software you can export
all of our data as a vcf file and work
with it at any software
package of your choice of course
i want to show you one example of a
familial cancer
in a family that was studied at md
anderson where four children had the
same extremely rare tumor
they've been analyzed with every modern
genomic method
with no success but when we imaged them
with bio nano when we imaged their
genome
we saw this region here that was
interesting we're showing you just a
number of molecules
you can already see with the naked eye
that there's some patterns in there so
we built a consensus genome map that
consists of the average spacing of these
labels and when we compare that
to hg19 you see perfect alignment on the
left but something's going on there on
the right
we also built another map for the other
allele
which is wild type and aligns perfectly
with the reference
now when you compare this to the
controls shown on top
uh that are not involved in this cancer
uh you see that the
two alleles they're aligned perfectly
with the reference now in this patient
here and keep in mind this is the
germline not the tumor
you see that there's a 38kb fragment
that's present in six standard copies
now how do we know this so sure we know
this because we have single molecules
that spend the entire 230 kb
of that repeat and that is really the
strength of our technology
we observe uh structural variants
directly on single molecules
compared to ngs where they are inferred
algorith algorithmically
after uh you know chopping up the genome
in other pieces
and what's important finding here is
that that gene unlabeled there
on the left is known to be mutated
in this tumor pathway so this is really
an interesting
finding for this family that was
impossible to detect
with other methods now for cancer
specifically
where samples can be very heterogeneous
and you can have subclonal
populations of cells we developed
another pipeline that we call the rare
pipeline
and it allows you to detect very low
allele fraction structural variants
with very high sensitivity and very high
ppv so low false positives
and we can go down to as low as one
percent variant allele fraction
so at 300x effective coverage so that
means just a single flow cell
run for a day on our instrument we can
detect
translocations inversions deletions
insertions and duplications down to five
percent allele fraction
keep in mind that it's completely
unbiased there's no amplification
there's no panel
we show you every structural variant
down to five percent of the diffraction
and if you want to run your instrument
longer for two to four days
then we can go down to as little as one
percent allele fraction
so that means that if just two percent
of the cells in your tumor have a
heterozygous translocation
anywhere we will still pick that up
no other technology can do this or comes
even close to that
so i want to show you a couple examples
from cancer keep in mind that
all of these findings really apply to
genetic disease as well
cancer is typically a little harder so
i'll show you those examples
first so the first paper i want to talk
about is from
dr jim brooch who is director of
personalized medicine at the penn state
institute in hershey and
he published work on a dozen leukemia
samples that were analyzed with ngs and
bionano
and in this paper he shows a number of
variants
found in different leukemia samples like
here's a case of a non-hodgkin's
lymphoma where the t lymphocytes were
cultured
as a germline control but when you look
at the lymphoma cells
you actually see that there's a three
megabase inversion
this inversion was missed by ngs was not
seen on a karyotype because it's just
too small for that
but what's important here is that it
cuts right through the gene p10 that's
labeled in red
at the bottom p10 is a known tumor
suppressor gene
and when this gene is disrupted it has a
severe effect on the
development of the tumor and also on the
treatment really because there are
dozens of compounds and trials
now dozens of trials going on for
compounds that rescue
p10 mutations the slip in the other
allele was picked up with sequencing
so here you have this combination where
the bionano optical mapping of genome
imaging was really essential
to find this variant that could
immediately have changed the treatment
for this patient now in the paper they
show
a number of leukemia genes on the left
there that were affected by multiple
variants and multiple samples
that makes a lot of sense but they also
found a lot of other cancer-associated
genes that were not previously
linked to leukemia and on top of that
dozens and dozens
of genes that were not previously linked
to cancer at all
that were affected in multiple samples
so there's an enormous potential of
discovery here
just out of the single simple study on
12 leukemia genomes
and that is really because there simply
was no method to look at gene and white
structural variation
with this type of sensitivity before so
these studies just couldn't be done
there's still an enormous amount of
new genes and new biomarkers to be
discovered
and actually if you pay attention to
this study
they followed up by looking at some of
these genes looking at the tcag
tcga data and finding that they really
do affect
survival in some of these patients
another study that just came out in bio
archives is of great interest to us
this is from a team at the radabout
university namek in the netherlands and
they've always been at the forefront of
bringing new technology into the clinic
and that's what they're doing here by
comparing our technology
our genome imaging technology with
standard cytogenetics
and standard cytogenetics is karyotyping
as we've shown before
there's fish which works well but you
only use specific probes to specific
genes so it has a very limited
field of view in a sense and in
chromosomal microarray
that's only capable of detecting uh
duplications and deletions
uh but cannot find um the exact
structure
and kind of find balanced events so in
the study they compared bionano against
all of these methods combined in 48
samples
and amazingly found 100 concordance
meaning that in
all 48 samples by nano picked up all the
clinically
reported structural variants from
karyotype and
fish and array combined that is just
incredible and many
sequencing based methods have tried to
do this and failed to replace
cytogenetics
we are the first technology that can
actually do that and
um besides these more standard variants
like a bcr-able translocation that they
found
they had a sample with complex
chromothripsis that was resolved
unambiguously
uh by bionano and on top of that they
also
discovered 19 novel gene fusions
never before reported and some of them
have a
translocation partner that is known to
be important like bcr
at the bottom there but with the new
translocation partner that had not been
reported
before so again an enormous amount of
discovery potential in this type of data
and the power of our technology really
is
that we could take a workflow like you
see on the left there the cyto lab
workflow where you have depending on the
input source
and the tests that you're doing an
enormous amount of different procedures
with different equipment
with culturing of cells with different
microscope and array scanners and
and hybridization uh
ovens and all of that and all of that
could be replaced with the workflow on
the right
there's just a simple single instrument
single uh dna extraction workflow
and then a single piece of software that
can give you array data fish data
karyotype data
all of that combined
we have many more exciting cancer
discovery stories
here is a sample a pair of
hepatocellular carcinomas
that were analyzed two liver tumors that
looked fairly identical
under a microscope but if you look on
the left you see a
fairly simple karyotype or a simple
genome with just a few rearrangements
but on the right you see a massive
number of rearrangements
massive changes in copy number and
translocations
and the difference between the two is
really the lack of presence of
replication stress
and we also found the cause of that the
figure above that there you see
that we detected the hbv so the
hepatitis b
virus insertion site right upstream
of a cyclin e1 gene and that cycling
gene
regulates the cell cycle the viral
promoter turns on that cycling gene
makes that cell replicate
much faster than the dna replication can
keep up with
and that causes this genome to really
fall apart so not only do we see
the signature of that replication stress
but we also
see the cause of that that hepatitis
insertion
i want to switch to genetic disease and
finish up with a few more examples here
here is a patient with duchenne muscular
dystrophy
severe degenerative muscular dystrophy
that affects boys
because it's excellent and it's a very
very large gene
the largest gene in the human genome
really with 79 exons
and this patient had all the symptoms of
duchenne's
but was analyzed with microarray with
whole genome sequence
with mlpa to look for the presence or
absence of all of the
exons all the exons were pcr amplified
and sanger sequenced
and yet no variants were found in this
gene
but when it was analyzed by nano we
immediately picked up this five megabase
inversion which you see here
which cos which cuts the dystrophin gene
labeled dmd on the right
are right in half so this disrupted the
gene entirely
uh evidence of this was found uh in the
rna after muscle biopsy
picked up immediately by bioneno they're
showing it twice here with two labeling
enzymes
uh mark ebbert who's also speaking the
speaker at the symposium
uh used our technology to identify a
repeat expansion at the c9 or f72 gene
which is the cause of als or one of the
causes of als
and what you're looking at here is a
number of alleles
a number of maps that were built by our
system
with various sizes of the insertion so
you see that the spacing between these
labels from top to bottom
increases all the way to 32 kb insertion
and we see several molecules supporting
each of these expansions
and this comes from a single brain
biopsy from a patient
who died of als so not only are we able
to span
and measure that repeat expansion that
consists entirely out of g's and c's
you cannot pcr amplified is no modern
technology can
span that by nano can we also see this
in a mosaic pattern so we can tell you
exactly what allele fraction there is
for each of these expansions in the
brain
now there's another muscular dystrophy
um where by nano plays an important part
and that is fshd
that stands for fascio scapular humeral
muscular dystrophy
it's a muscle dystrophy that affects
mostly the shoulders and the arms
and the face and the only way to
diagnose this
method is with saturn blood using
radioactive labeling
a lot of universities and centers have
to get rid of this radioactive labeling
or want to
and the reason why this only works with
saturn blot is because there is a very
large repeat
septal numeric of chromosome 4 and one
that contracts below 10 copies
then it causes the disease by changing
the chromatin structure
now to genotype this you have to exactly
measure this large repeat
and you have to genotype the presence of
the pathogenic or non-pathogenic allele
all of this is very complex but bionano
does this very beautifully as you see
there
the magenta part represents the repeat
and you see
a contracted repeat on top in a patient
sample
and then a wild type repeat in a control
sample below that
and our enfocus software generates a
summary report with a genotype
that then can be used by labs to develop
a clinical test
and that's exactly what perkin element
genomics and university of iowa have
already done
university of iowa is the largest center
in north america for fshd testing and
they are
using our technology for that
now if you want to get by nanodata
we made it easier than ever for you to
access that
starting from the right you can simply
purchase a system starts at 150
000 and then the cost per genome is just
four hundred and fifty dollars
we also have reagent rental models where
you commit to 120 genomes in six months
and we give you an instrument for free
to use
or you can use our full service offering
where you simply send our samples
send your samples to buy nano and we
give you the data back
and that starts at 650
i would highly recommend you have a look
at our website we have a library of
videos
from presentations from other scientists
who have used our technology and
made some spectacular findings with that
and with that i want to thank you for
your time
you're welcome to ask any questions here
and we will get back to you
as quickly as possible with them so
thank you